Gonna make me blush.
I do.
I was working for a gay organization.
I was in a lesbian bar in Texas.
Um,
Dallas and I,
uh,
was up until that point had a boyfriend,
thought I was completely straight and
she hit on me.
And I remember feeling very flattered
and a surprisingly interested.
She was confident.
I think it was the confidence that
really pulled me in.
They surprised me because I have a
master's degree in women's studies.
When I was in graduate school,
I lived with a troop of drag kings and,
um,
I had been around the lesbian community
for years and was never interested in
anyone in the community.
So when this happened,
I thought the question had already been
settled for me.
Um,
that I was a straight ally working for a
gay organization.
I was working for glad at the time.
And um,
so it surprised me and I went home and I
called my sister and I said,
this woman hit on me and I don't know,
I think I kind of liked it.
And she was like,
oh,
it's no big deal.
I've kissed lots of girls.
Who Cares?
Um,
so,
um,
and she was straight also.
So that was surprising too.
I didn't know that about her.
And um,
you know,
I remember at the time it was a little,
it was probably a little scary and
nothing,
you know,
nothing happened that evening,
but it got me thinking and it got me
thinking in a very different way.
And it sounds cheesy,
but I really started,
I,
you know,
I can remember driving down the street
and envisioning my life completely
differently,
envisioning getting married but to a
woman,
an envisioning having a life but with a
woman and coming home to a woman and I
really,
you know,
I dunno,
it was like this door opened that hadn't
been opened before and I thought,
Huh,
that could be my life.
And it seemed really exciting and
really,
right.
It just made sense.
I had different experiences.
I think that most people,
because I was working at a gay
organization and they for a couple of
years had gotten used to me being,
you know,
the straight ally that work to the gay
organizations.
So I had to go there and sort of come
out in a reverse sense and say to
everybody,
look,
I,
I thought I was straight too,
but I'm not,
um,
I'm actually gay.
And it was surprising.
A lot of people were really,
I remember being very nervous and very,
I felt a lot of,
you know,
I was proud to be a straight ally and
work at a gay organization and I felt
really,
I carried a lot of responsibility to
sort of educate other straight people
and bring people in.
And so I felt,
I think there was some part of me that
felt like I was maybe letting people
down.
And then I got over that pretty quickly
and thought,
well,
this is the whole point.
This is what we're fighting for,
this is who I am.
And it's okay.
There were some people at work that were
sort of like,
that's fine,
you're experimenting,
just,
you know,
test it out.
And I was,
which sort of irked me a little bit
because I thought,
no,
I'm not,
this isn't just,
you know,
a flaming,
it's like,
I really,
I think this is who I am.
So it just shows that we all have,
you know,
our own biases and assumptions that we
carry around.
And then when I came out to my parents,
I was very naive and my parents are very
liberal.
Um,
my dad was a retired as a school
superintendent and my mom was a social
worker and,
um,
was,
uh,
worked at a black community center up in
Syracuse and they were very liberal
compared to every other,
you know,
all of their friends,
all of our neighbors.
So I thought this would be a nonissue.
And they had gay friends,
you know,
my mom was the person at work who would
stand up for the gay guy.
And I've never heard my dad tell an anti
gay joke or anything like that.
And when I came out,
um,
you know,
I was very surprised because my mother
has such a traditional,
like reaction and she's not a
traditional person,
which was like,
oh my God,
what?
You're never going to have kids.
You're never going to,
you had a husband and have this life.
And you know,
I was like,
who are you?
This is not,
I've never heard you say things like
this.
Um,
and it took many years for her to
eventually become okay with that.
Uh,
so it was a process and I didn't expect
it to be,
so that was surprising.
Okay.